[Applause]
according to a recent poll only 28 of
voters approve of the job that vice
president kamala harris is currently
doing since taking office harris hasn't
been in the spotlight a lot and many
people have been wondering where she is
what was that
i don't know
it kind of sounded like vice president
kamala harris
bet you can't find me
it is kamala harris oh where did she go
run run amber see if you can catch her
i'm gonna lie gotcha dang it
how does she run away so quickly
easy i'm wearing my converse
ah she is so cool
try and catch me
what happens if i do do i get three
wishes you get something better than
three wishes you get subsidized child
care
oh
oh
sneaky little vice president and your
beautiful suppressed
amber there
i'm the vp but you can't find me if you
do i'll increase taxes for the wealthy
tahiti
first you kabala get back here
whoa how is she doing that i don't know
i think she's gone
or am i derek she's behind you remember
and demand stupid dead cancellation
never
oh no she ran into the audience we'll
never find her
madame vice president where are you we
know you're in here somewhere
i can sense your power suit and strong
stepmom energy
excuse me sir
have you seen a rascally vice president
running around here somewhere
oh the vice president neville
you sound an awful lot like vice
president harris doing a french accent
hey it is you you found me
madam vice president where have you been
hiding i'm not hiding the vice president
just doesn't do
look at mike pence or al gore or joe
biden
no one got mad at them for not doing
enough
the public is harder on me because i'm a
woman of color and hey look over there
it's idris elba and he's giving away
free smooches what where
i'm outta here
oh man she got away
but you know what she's right
kyla harris is not doing a bad job yep
not doing a bad job at all look dick
cheney shot somebody compared to him
she's doing a great job
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you